je t'assure qu'il est il est vraiment
excellent
des meilleurs que j'ai jamais préparé
non non
et tu me dis toujours pourtant qu'il ne
faut jamais refuser ce que l'on ne
connaît pas oui c'est vrai mais là c'est
différent bon alors tu peux bien faire
un effort tant pis tant pis
je ne mangerai pas de gloubiboulga je
n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un donc si têtu
pour faire j'en ai déjà mangé une fois
quel mauvaise foi alors tu avais à peine
posé le doigt dessus que tu faisais déjà
la grimace avant de l'avoir mis sur ta
langue mais je l'avais goûté
non non faut vraiment apprécier il faut
en manger au moins trois grandes
cuillères je n'en mangerai pas tu en
mangeras non quasiment tu devrais
respecter mes goûts comme je respecte
les tiens bon écoute je te promets que
si tu n'aimes pas ça je ne t'en
proposerai plus jamais
c'est promis c'est promis si tu en
manges trois cuillères
2 non non non on ne peut pas apprécier
bon d'accord bon alors trois cuillères
mais pas trop grosses non non allez
alors attention
une cuillère pour Julie
oh
que c'est mauvais j'ai jamais rien mangé
aussi
une deuxième cuillère pour Monsieur duc
non
attends un peu au moins que se
passe-t-il franchement c'est fait mal
non non pas du tout il commence à
apprécier la délicieuse saveur du
merveilleux gloubi-boulga curieux façon
d'apprécier je l'entends crier de
terreur depuis le fond du jardin Julie
c'est affreux hein
arrête-toi non non il a promis d'en
manger trois cuillères tant que ça il
paraît que c'était la troisième cuillère
qu'on commence à trouver ça bon très
bien bon courage allez alors une
deuxième cuillère
pour le facteur
[Musique]
il y a peut-être un tout petit peu trop
de moutarde mais d'un autre côté
excuse-moi je t'avais oublié François
donne-moi la troisième cuillère de
gloubi-boulga tu commences à aimer ça
quand on veut une grande assiette
dépêche-toi de mener la troisième
cuillère pour que ce soit fini le plus
vite possible tu es sûr François mais
bien sûr j'ai promis tu vas voir
celle-là tu la trouveras très bonne
allez une troisième cuillère pour
Monsieur du snob
[Musique]
alors et François qu'est-ce qui t'arrive
dis-moi quelque chose
et parle
quasiment raison
[Musique]
il a dit vrai
à la troisième cuillère
le globile bulgare est bien meilleur tu
vois Julie j'ai toujours dit qu'il n'y
avait rien de meilleur que le
gloubi-boulga
[Musique]
évidemment c'est peut-être un peu lourd
à digérer mais
pour que j'ai mal Julie soit gentil
raconte moi chez moi il faut que j'aille
me coucher
c'est pourtant du gloubi-boulga le
premier choix
n'a pas un tomates quasius évidemment
c'est une petite nature oh là là elle
est bien
garde le kiosque et c'est de distraire
les enfants avant que je revienne
je comprends pas François est vraiment
douillet j'avais juste mis un petit
morceau de savon de Marseille pour lui
faire une farce et il est malade bon
allez les enfants venez là prenez vous
asseoir
venez tous venez on va faire un jeu vous
voulez bien on va faire un jeu nous
allons jouer à
quoi pourrait-on bien jouer manger une
idée j'ai une idée je vais vous donner
la recette du gloubiboulga d'accord bon
pour faire un excellent gloubi-boulga il
vous faut d'abord du chocolat au lait de
préférence vous le râpez vous le
mélanger à de la confiture de fraises
vous pilez des bananes vous mélangez
bien le tout ensuite vous rajoutez la
moutarde et les saucisses de Toulouse
tiède mais cru
attends bon et pour améliorer vous
mettez un petit morceau de savon de
Marseille non non quand je suis bête non
ça c'était une blague que j'avais fait à
François excusez-moi bon vous avez
compris bon qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
maintenant bon ben je recommence alors
une deuxième fois alors pour faire un
excellent globi bulgare il faut du
chocolat au lait que vous râpez bien fin
bon ben écoute je vais vous redonner
pour la 15e fois la recette pour réussir
un super extra gloubi-boulga géant
délicieux alors il faut d'abord du
chocolat au lait de préférence vous
qu'est-ce que c'est pas Julie comment va
François il va beaucoup mieux mais
pourquoi les enfants s'ennuient-il tu
avais promis de les amuser mais je ne
fais que ça je leur donne pour la 15e
fois la recette du gloubi-boulga avec ou
sans savon de Marseille
comment as-tu deviné c'était très simple
j'ai cherché toute la matinée Mon nous
savons de Marseille que j'avais acheté
hier soir et quand François m'a dit que
ce qu'il avait rendu malade dans le
gloubiboulga c'était le goût du savon de
Marseille j'ai tout compris
idiotes j'avoue que la raison quasimir
avec tout ton attirail j'aurais pu
éviter de te poser une telle question
tu vois ce n'est pas toujours moi qui
fait les erreurs mon feu que j'ai mûr
j'ai jamais dit ça et tu sais tout le
monde peut se tromper même les personnes
les plus intelligentes il y a aucune
honte à ça ah ah François a fait une
erreur François a fait une erreur
François
que je dis une bêtise je crois que je
vais en dire deux fois plus
douter mais tu vas pêcher dans le nez ou
dans l'eau de rivière la mer est trop
loin alors je vais la battre dans la
rivière ah là-bas et que vas-tu pêcher
attends regarde
je vais pêcher
tout ça tout ça et ben dis donc Casimir
tu vas jamais pouvoir manger autant de
poissons mais ce n'est pas du tout pour
les manger c'est pour le nouvel aquarium
de l'île aux enfants
ah mais c'est très bien sa Casimir alors
tu vas capturer les poissons afin que
les enfants puissent aller les admirer
c'est formidable ça et quel genre de
poisson et bien regarde il y a une
murène
pas bouger attends
attends attends Nathalie les enfants et
Agnès qu'est-ce qui va faire venez
Casimir il a des problèmes
Casimir son va la pêche mais il a tout
mélanger les poissons d'eau de mer et
les poissons d'eau douce alors on va
l'aider comme on peut vous êtes d'accord
faites bien attention
casimirène une murène une murène est-ce
que c'est un poisson d'eau de mer ou un
poisson de rivière
à votre avis
une murène c'est un poisson d'eau de mer
une seule
rivière
un poisson de mer
un Macron
un poisson
[Musique]
un poisson de rivière la brême est un
poisson de rivière après bon un espadon
un poisson de mer c'est ça
ensuite donc une tâche une tanche alors
une tâche
rivière
un saumon un saumon
[Musique]
Ie
c'était un peu les deux c'est à dire que
le saumon vit dans la mer mais tous les
ans à l'automne il remonte le cours de
la rivière pour aller faire ses petits
voilà comment vas-tu attraper tous tes
poissons j'ai ma canne à pêche mon
épuisette et puis ça
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça c'est que ça
vous ne devinez pas facile
ça c'est pour les pieuvres on met
l'entonnoir dans l'eau la pieuvre
s'approche elle voit les 8 morceaux de
pain alors elle met ses 8 tentacules
dans l'entonnoir et puis quand elle a
attrapé les 8 morceaux de pain elle tire
mais elle ne peut plus sortir alors on
sort l'entonnoir de l'eau avec la
pieuvre
[Musique]
et ensuite
j'ai cette chose là
une ampoule un interrupteur et une prise
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire avec ça et
bien je mets le fil dans l'eau tu mets
le fil dans l'eau et lorsque électrique
c'est pour les règles électriques mort
la prise
voilà et tu as pêché leur électrique bah
c'est formidable bon et puis on t'a
encore une chose encore une
voilà ça un gros clown
et qu'est-ce que c'est beaucoup de colle
alors qu'est-ce que tu fabriques avec ça
alors on met le Cloud dans l'eau tu mets
le tout dans l'eau
je mets de la colle sur la tête du clou
voilà ici le requin marteau arrive c'est
pour les requins marteaux
et je tire voilà et ça y est et tu as
des chaînes autre poisson dis donc
quasimir c'est très bien tout ça mais il
y a un petit ennui le requin marteau
l'art électrique le poisson chat la
pieuvre tout ça
on les trouve pas dans la rivière c'est
ça
enfin j'ai pensé à tout voilà et tu as
trouvé une solution ouais et quelle est
la solution la voilà la solution
celle de mer et comment vas-tu je mets
du sel dans la rivière et tous les
poissons croient que c'est la mer